as charlie morton is on the hill for the
braves time for charlie to get things
going it's been a slog for him the last
three or four starts two down here in
the first heading cameron mabin makes
his mitts debut his 10th different major
league team over 15 seasons and he
swings the first one chops it toward
third very easy inning for morton nine
pitches eight strikes two ground outs
that's what we came to see david
peterson coming off one of his best
starts in tampa bay on friday night went
into the eighth inning seven or third
innings he pitched it was a strong start
especially with those nine k's facing
ronald acuna junior a tough hitter right
hand better but he's slumping
kate strike three called and peterson's
got to strike out to start his night so
after all the breaking stuff he froze
him with a fastball we head to the top
of the second here at truest park dom
smith leads off top of the second
against charlie morton
up the middle
and into center field a base set for dom
and the mets have the first base runner
of the night the lead off man on here in
the second inning for james mccann
blew it right on by mccann nothing wrong
with that 95 miles an hour jose peraza
had a double as last time up last night
ground ball out to third could be two
riley to ozzy ozzy to freddie there is a
double play and that takes care of the
match at the top of the second to the
top of the third and khalil lee is the
next mets hitter there's the breaking
ball of beauty second strikeout for
charlie morton two up two down and the
pitcher's coming up that's the perfect
example you don't see that curveball
down in triple a no double eye peterson
oh for eight
breaking ball throws him up beautiful
curveball out of charlie mort way into
the bottom of the third son he's got the
braves pitcher charlie morton one for
nine swinging a missed strike three it
was the change up again and david
peterson's retired nine in a row he's
made it look easy jonathan vr leads off
the fourth against morton vr fly to left
his first time the arc cranks one to
deep right field back goes acuna looks
up and it's out of here jonathan vr is
struck again he homered last night from
the right side he hits one from the left
side tonight his fourth of the year and
the mets
go in front one to nothing chalk another
one up for the benchmap two down for
dominic smith
he swings and misses for strike three
and another good curveball out of
charlie mort into the bottom of the
fourth inning matt's leading the braves
one to nothing it is 10 up 10 down for
david peterson let's see if freddie
freeman can change that
and there's the start freddie freeman
jumps on the first pitch didn't get to
two strikes that's the first atlanta
base runner and here comes marcel
and ozuna hits a double play ball grab
by lindora the step and fire and they
turn two to end the inning neatly done
by lindor for the six six three double
play we go to the bottom of the pit so
contreras at first riley's at third
let's see if heredia can make peterson
pay here he's have 83 two out runs
line drive he's got another one base hit
retired
contreras is going to throw out an
anchor at second base
already against his tied his ninth rbi
and where did that ball go
line to right center so the braves are
level they've out hit the mets now and
charlie morton can help himself perhaps
center field
charlie morton puts the braves in front
they're swagging early in the count and
reaping the reward well now the mets
have to face ronald lacuna junior two in
two on two out there he goes the pitch
is downstairs ball gets away here comes
here
hill sliding safely mccann's done a good
job of corralling some pitches this
inning but he couldn't keep that one
from bouncing away over toward the mets
dugout and the braves are on top three
to one base is loaded with ozuna coming
up and drew smith is going to come in
with a big out to get here
and he hits a ground ball right up the
middle knocked down by peraza still last
time and a low throw and dom with a
great snag to stay on the bag and save
peraza an error and save a couple of
runs charlie desperately wanting a
shutdown inning after getting three runs
eight in a row retired by morton since
vr took him deep in the fourth inning
yes cut out and missed shut down inning
for charlie morton he has struck out
eight we go to the bottom the sixth
they're going to walk her radio let's
see if charlie's gonna hit as great as
morton is pitched with two outs the
braves making a decision to go for
insurance runs here bases are full of
braves with two out and the 1-0 line the
other way caught at third by vr
side retired well sandoval hit a sizzler
but right where vr was stationed we
played six braves up three to one the
mets have two on and two out so now
peraza with the tying runs aboard and he
pulls one on the ground that's a fair
ball going down the line and into the
corner dom will score mccann to third
he's going to be held up there by gary d
sarcina it's an rbi double for jose
perazza and the mets pull within a run
it's three to two
and the mitzvah tying run on third the
go-ahead run on second with two out luke
jackson will come in to face tomas nito
breaking ball popped up shallow center
coming in her radio coming in he won't
get there a base hit two runs are going
to score peraza to the plate safe
standing up tomas vito delivers again a
pinch hit bloop two run single and the
mets take a four to three lead here in
the seventh they've had the tying run on
to lead things off here in the seventh
inning freddie freeman will bat now
he lofts this one to deep right center
field back in the gap goes lee and he
made the catch he did it again
oh khalil lee
khalil lee makes a spectacular catch to
rob freeman what a play home eighth down
a run so first and third nobody out and
the braves poised to try and tire take
the lead with william contreras at the
plate
that's looped out to rainfield down for
a base hit and a 4-4 ball game the young
man comes through and whistles one
through the right side look at contreras
pumped the fist runners at first and
second one out so now a-ray adrianza
will be the batter and adriana takes
outside the runner goes and he's down at
third
mccann guns down swanson trying to steal
third swanson running on his own
contreras did not follow and that's a
huge second out one and two to adrianza
swung out and miss strike three side
retired barnes gets him with a cutter
and what a job by jacob barnes so we go
to the ninth clean slate four to four
will smith him go ahead and run it third
and two out now the bat in the hands of
jose
little looper hit toward third and
riley's got it smith pitches out of it
the braves overcome a couple of wild
pitches
[Applause]
all that ronald has done in the big
leagues he has yet to hit a walk-off
home run so no time like the present kid
get after it high fly ball center field
deep at the track
it's gone
ronaldo county just sent a shock wave to
the ballpark and the braves walk it off
and true his part partner you never
forget your first one and ronald acuna
jr hits one into the atlanta bullpen
and if ever a one-run win in middle of
may was important
man oh man was this one important